My name is Nagla Rizk. I am a professor of economics and founding director of the
Access to Knowledge for Development
Center at the American University in
Cairo School of Business. My take on AI
and inclusion comes from the stance that
we need neither to romanticize nor
demonize the technologies. But rather
democratize and harness for the
betterment of human lives. So I bring a
voice of the south, from the South to
this debate. I think the discourse should
be inclusive, the discourse itself should be inclusive to look at how these
technologies from the sense of use of
the technologies and the production of
technologies, and in that sense we need
to think of how we can devise business
models that actually engage players from
different parts of the world and that
lead to the openness of knowledge from a paradigm of openness, from a paradigm of
engagement and sharing. It's very
important to realize that the debates
regarding AI and inclusion are not
entirely new. They're quite similar to
the issues that came about with
the digital technologies, the Internet,
looking at the potential of bringing
development, but at the same time the
opposite argument of how the digital
divide is actually exacerbated by these
new technologies. A key area that
needs to be tackled is actually context
based research. For example the future of
work in the global north as opposed to
other areas when there is informal labor:
what does AI mean for the type of jobs
and the type of tasks that are taking
place. Another area is business models:
what business models are appropriate for
the development of AI based models,
production and use. What is the
concept of value? What is the concept of
intellectual property models: patent
pools, knowledge sharing, data commons. All
of these issues, there has to be a
conversation to inform the discourse, the
discourse itself has to be inclusive.